hello darling it's me again yours
cruelly elvira in her new memoir yours
cruelly elvira the star whose real name
is cassandra peterson reveals that she's
been in a same-sex partnership for
nearly 20 years peterson who was
previously married to mark pearson from
1981 to 2003 opens up about her finding
true love at a hollywood gym writing
that she spotted a quote bad boy who she
soon realized was in fact a bad girl a
trainer named teresa weirson and the two
quickly became close friends once their
respective relationships ended peterson
says wierson moved in with her and
eventually her feelings for theresa
became romantic peterson writes i felt
so confused this just wasn't me i was
stunned that i'd been friends with her
for so many years and never noticed our
chemistry
19 years later the actress says that her
partner makes her feel quote safe
blessed and truly loved adding i'm very
aware that there will be some who will
be disappointed and maybe even angry but
i have to live with myself and at this
point in my life i've got to be truthful
about who i am